have you ever wanted to go on a balloon
ride hey everyone welcome to the behind
the scenes for the Metal Gear Solid
balloon ride perhaps your hot air
balloon landed here and now you're
watching this video they have this
ridiculous element called the Fulton
extraction where you can pretty much
take anything from the game pull it up
into the sky and bring it back to your
base we decided to just make a whole
video about a random soldier going on
his very first balloon ride when looking
for a place to shoot this video we went
to our old trusty friend Google Maps and
what did we find a little place off the
15 freeway called Mormon rocks and
without even scouting it we just drove
on out there and shot the whole video in
one day so to get out to set like
alright we're gonna shoot this
tournament we give you a half and half
then it's like alright the Reds are
networking we had given that camera
beating you know we were shooting with
it for two months all the parts were
just covered in dust so when we arrived
on set we tried to turn it on it was not
working everything was going wrong so
Carmichael is like looks like we have to
use the BTS camera there you go we had
to whip out our old fs100 we've used
that for lots of old videos dubstep guns
minecraft for last minecart it's a
smaller camera in flight er it was great
there's a breeze to shoot with you'll
see from the footage it honestly looks
pretty good this is the very first video
we shot this year coming off of our very
large two-month long movie project and
so I kind of took some of that and tried
to apply it to this shoot most of it
really just is being super chill the
entire time you're filming because like
any shoot small problems arise and the
best way to handle it on set is by
keeping a level head another thing I
learned on that set is communication is
key you know when setting up shots and
when talking with actors you know just
be very very direct we've seen snake out
of poke it's kind of like leaking up
behind him right when he fishes that
thought we see watch norm go around them
if they're good and also you'll notice
that the effects of this piece are very
similar to a lot of ones we've already
done basically the majority of effects
consist of doing 3d scans of Ren turning
out into a ragdoll animation and then
just doing some basic 3d tracking in the
scene you'll remember other videos like
GTA we use very similar effects in it
where people are getting hit and turning
into rag dolls and stuff like that
I was just so excited to finish this
video I just sat down and I just banged
almost every single effect in almost two
days who played snake in this video the
one
the talented cote Galloway if you want
to see his other stuff check out our
videos
superheroes vs. gaming heroes or the
poacher overall this has been one of the
most enjoyable shoots we've done over
the last year we've picked a fun easy
location to shoot at it was a
straightforward storyline and Sam did
all the effects more fun for me and you
well Sam does all the work
no I really just hope you guys enjoyed
it I mean this is just the kind of our
own little homage to what was an awesome
game series thanks for watching guys and
if you have any questions hit us up on
Twitter or leave a comment below